[Musique]
espace exceptionnel propriété du
Conservatoire du littoral la Pointe au
Sel à Saint-Leu et le seul site où l'on
fabrique du sel à la Réunion alors ce
site est remarquable à plusieurs titres
il est remarquable pour son patrimoine
écologique mais aussi pour son
patrimoine historique il a il permet de
faire vivre un vieux métier le métier de
Sonier et ce site là il il est dans dans
la mémoire à la fois écologique mais
dans la mémoire historique et mentale de
de la Réunion pour Jean-Claude casanov
le métier de Sonier est avant tout une
histoire de
famille soigné depuis l'âge depuis ça
fait 8 ans déjà soigné soigné père en
fils génération qu génération ah ben
c'est une gloire en fin de compte c'est
une gloire de reprendre un relève là la
relève c'est fait à vivre un savoir à
faire en fin de compte garder le
savoir un grand savoir
ez l'eau de la mer est pompée vers les
bassins et c'est avec l'évaporation que
le sel est produit c'est lorsqu'il est
cristallisé que les soners le récoltent
et qu'il le laissent sécher au
soleil voilà on va prend on va pomper
l'eau trouve au fond dans la mer un tu
qui se trouve dans la mer l'eau va
ramener bassin un bassin tête en
haut bin un bassin qu' sappelle stockage
ensuite il y a 23 bassins de cantation
ter mes que l'eau va descendre il aura
puisson
faire
gr
c'est qu'on s fait en qu' on va
ramasser au moins 5 TR récoltes d'un
bassin et en va renettoyer le bassin
pour avoir nveau bon sal bon à saintleu
l'eau de mer est particulièrement chargé
en chlorure de sodium en calcium et en
magnésium une eau pure un oleillement
généreux des pluies rares caractérise
cette zone de la côte ouest de l'île il
faut savoir que pointe sel c'est
vraiment le meilleur site à l'Î de la
Réunion pour avoir du bon sel pourquoi
tout simplement euh endroit mais
vraiment très ensoleillé le petit vent
léger qui passe et aussi surtout pas de
pluie hein pas de pluie c'est l'endroit
qui pleut presque jamais ici à l'île de
la réunon sauf arrivé fin d'année début
d'année avec la saison des cyclones
autrement pas de pluie ici à la pointe
selle ici on est sur une pointe qui
rentre dans la mer Ros de basalt de
couleur noir mais qui qui qui qui
absorbe bien le soleil et euh très
proche de la merde du coup coup c'est
vraiment l'endroit idéal pour avoir du
du bon sel trois sortes de sel
alimentaires sont produits ici la fleur
de sel le gros sel et le sel pilon le de
sel c'est uniquement
pourade comment ça le goû relever le
plat et le grosel on va mettre le sel on
va directement dans la Maram dans
castole S pilon il faut le craser avec
les épices les épices ça don s pilon là
le piment tout ça va craser le Conseil
départemental gestionnaire du site
depuis 2003 a confié l'exploitation des
salines et l'entretien de l'espace
naturel au groupement pour la
conservation de l'environnement et
l'insertion professionnelle on ass sur
la protection du site on assure
l'entretien la valorisation et surtout
on préserve le métier de Sonier qui qui
est le métier par lequel on arrive à
produire du sel Paris que c'est un
métier en voie de disparition il y a
plus que quatre sonniers à la Réunion
qui sont qui travaillent toujours grâce
au soutien du Département et il faut
savoir que la production de sel c'est
c'est vraiment une valeur patrimoniale
sur l'île et nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pouvoir préserver ce
patrimoine le musée du sel vous présente
cet or blanc de lîle de sa découverte à
sa production et à sa consommation tout
en vous expliquant sa composition et ses
propriétés l'écomusée de la pointe au
selle a ouvert ses portes en janvier
2007 depuis sa fréquentation en fait le
3oème équipement muséal du
[Musique]
département